what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we are here today to watch
the black adam official trailer numero
dos johnny how are you i am hot and
sweaty how are you i am also sweaty and
hot coy how are you hot and sweaty for
some black adam i heard me bet you are i
bet you are i've been studying up on
black adam but this guy he already knows
so much about black adam just the
society of america he knows like
everything's gonna happen in this movie
he's gonna predict it all right so you
guys are gonna want to stick around
after the reaction here what he has to
say but yeah we're gonna watch trade for
the first time follow koi zhandro on
tick tock 15 seconds 30 seconds to three
minute videos covers i messed it up i
messed up the impressions okay i'm sorry
i was impressed
if you wanted like a bite-sized koi
impression
that's who i am
i like that i glitch in real time
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated leave a comment let's see
what's going on
[Music]
my son sacrificed his life to save me
these powers
are not a gift
but a curse
they'll be a gift
out of rage
[Music]
that's cool nice
oh
before innocent people start getting
hurt
he's been asleep for 5 000 years
you find us a cell that can hold them
we'll take care of the rest
who's on the team oh
[ __ ]
passport we don't need passports
we're the justice society holy crap damn
yeah these visuals are top-notch yeah
i'm not
peaceful and i never surrender
nor do i surrender
here we
oh yeah go i kneel before no one
[Music]
you didn't come here to seek justice
you came to exact revenge
[Music]
you believe you are not worthy
but fate does not make mistakes
you have two paths
so much rock walking in slow motion
you can be the destroyer of this world
[Music]
dude
oh yeah
[Laughter]
that was uh excellent excellent trailer
i like that much more than the first one
that was my very first thought was that
this is the i wish this was trailer one
yeah halfway through it i was like this
is so much better than that i mean i
like the first trailer but this really
felt like something special you got a
lot more of that like emotional depth
with what dwayne johnson has been
talking about that he's gonna bring with
black adam and of course seeing more of
the jsa i mean obviously it's gonna be
one of those kids like they didn't even
really show us who the main baddies
going to be in this film but obviously
you know it'll be at a point where it's
like okay amanda waller talking to what
looks like formerly the jsa and then is
going to have them go after black adam
they're probably going to team up fight
an ultimate baddie but what i loved
about this trailer in particular was
that it did feel pretty much like while
you got all the cool epic visuals which
look insane i was watching this and
because of the zack snyder almost
inspiration with the kind of visuals
they do with the fight scenes i was
going you know what it would be cool to
watch this guy fight superman
i didn't wear this shirt accidentally
today it looked pretty sweet not gonna
lie it looked pretty awesome and um it
looks like he would actually have a
character arc of someone who can find
himself feeling worthy and perhaps do
feel like he can perhaps be a hero
instead of just a villainous path but it
does look like a dark brooding
performance what you'd expect don't
worry koi you're going to rock this
video i'm just listening
don't worry i'm going to say like three
words
i'm listening john take it away i mean
what did you think about the visuals of
the jsa i mean we got to see some
cyclone powers for yeah dude we got to
see some cyclone powers we got to see
hawkman like oscillating through all
those different iterations of his
weaponry and stuff like that we got more
of dr fate's abilities and all the
prismic sort of force shields and things
he gets to project and uh yeah this is
easily the most enticing thing i have
seen related to black adam what so like
this was the most well-rounded trailer
like you said it looks like there will
actually be some emotional uh heft to
some of this and the visuals look
amazing even though we are seeing a lot
of like similar places to what we've
seen in the previous trailers the things
they added to flesh it out did just that
for me and yeah this got me actually
excited to see the movie and excited to
see how everybody at least that they're
featuring here interacts and i like that
they learned from the bvs trailer
playbook and they didn't show us the
probably inevitable them all teaming up
to fight a bigger body it's very easy
trailer and then all set up for an
actual gsa movie i imagine i believed in
an actual anti-hero situation taking
place that might be a hard one battle
that could lead to a uh you know a face
turn yeah yeah face turn good call
all right guys uh i got all right that's
it
so for me this did two really important
things the first of which you guys have
touched on which is it's a trailer for a
movie that comes out next month and it
didn't give us three minutes of new
footage it gave us maybe a minute and
it's dispersed throughout but it really
allowed the trailer to breathe it gave
us more emotion based off action and i
think the best action is action that has
emotion behind it i think a lot of the
times when we look at the greatest
action scenes of all time it's because
each punch lands twice you care about
both parties so you're really invested
in the action in a way so i love that
this added emotional half to the actual
rdc that gives us multiple things it
gives us lots and lots of new connective
tissue to
us to theorize but it also gives us a
bit more mystery when the movie comes
out and has two more hours as opposed to
us piecing together all the things we've
already seen and assembling a movie this
might be just the first two acts it
looks like and i like that we now have a
little bit more context without more
footage necessarily but the second thing
this did for me was two things i've
always wanted a sinister six movie that
made spider-man the antagonist i wanted
to have a ground level sinister six
where you've got like henchmen that
you're fighting spider-man and then
you're conflicted because everybody
loves spider-man how am i gonna root
against spider-man i thought that was
the best way to make a sinister six
movie and the other thing i've always
wanted is a justice league movie that
felt like the gods walked among us that
didn't have uh necessarily as much
baggage as you have to do with bunch of
movies leading up but i've always been
worried about a team movie to kick off
something i've always been worried that
if you skip a lot of steps this did that
for me we've not met any of these
characters yet we're about to meet
hawkman for the first time who's one of
my favorite comic characters aldous
hodge is going to crush it but i'm
already invested in him dr fate cyclone
i'm already there and we've got an atom
smasher all of these characters are many
of which predate marvel parallels right
so just because the movies beat them to
it doesn't mean the characters beat them
to it and i think what they're doing is
exceptional in showing the differences
in those characters because the everyday
person isn't going to know that dr fate
proceeded doctor strange the average
person isn't gonna recognize that adam
smasher is even maybe different than
ant-man people might not realize these
things if you don't read the comic books
so i think they did an exceptional job
going like hey we're skipping ahead to
this point but these are the differences
in our characters that scene of black
adam fighting dr fate feels like a panel
from a comic book and it's doing it
without feeling like they rushed to me
now obviously we haven't seen much more
than this but everything feels like it's
got more weight and it feels more earned
than i would have expected and it gives
us that sinister sixth thing where
you're invested in both sides of it
you're invested in your anti-hero in
this case as well as your team and
that's genius who do you think this this
villain is this red guy this red guy
villain who because this looks like this
is probably the main bat yeah that's
three frames or whatever and uh like
looks satanic like imagery look at that
star literally it looks like the devil
come to life i mean when i was
researching this movie i was hearing
rumors about the possibility of ishmael
showing up in here so i was looking them
up and it kind of looks like one of the
virgins i've seen of ishmael yeah
ishmael doesn't always look like that
sometimes he looks more human but there
is a new earth version that is very much
this iconography but he's more tied to
batman and the lazarus pit that also
might be trigon who's tied to like the
new teeton titans and raven's death and
if i'm not mistaken hawkman is a
character who is a descendant of someone
from like black adam's time and so i
imagine that this villain himself is
throughout time and like that's the
thing they've been yeah perhaps or
another descendant or something like
that but probably linked to the pharaoh
who ultimately um wanted to kill black
adam at the very top of this movie and
that's another thing that i'm liking
about what this trail is doing because
he does look very much anguished and
very much full of rage and they have
these like human characters i noticed
who have like nothing to do with anybody
else here i think that seems like the
eye lines there are like i understand
because this guy's from like thanagar so
they're gonna have to explain the
thanagarians aloud to the audience and i
think they're gonna be the people they
expand that to like there's gonna have
to be those characters that are like
excuse me what's going on that's all
yeah
and they're also
but it also will allow for um black adam
to possibly learn a little bit about the
good better side of humanity because
looks like when he's awakened you know i
like that line about he says i'm like
the magic magic is weak yeah yeah like
talking about the bullets and then there
might be some of that humor that a
little bit that fish out of water
quality with a person who is you know a
person out of time and like oh what is
what is modern day like which i'm sure
rock can do comedy we know that it's
gonna be fun to play with shazam too
because it had a lot of that fish out of
water but with the age thing right like
they were able to and these eventually
we hope to see these two conflict
because it is one continuity we've
teased black adam shazam so i'm really
excited for like those disparate fish
out of water stories to kind of come
together this looks incredible the
visuals are insane i got like that's
usually like a really easy thing to say
but in a day and age where you know
we're hearing all this talk about visual
effects departments getting pissed off
at studios and feeling like they're
under crunch time and pressure you know
which studio i'm referring to right now
but
we hear that talk all the time that it
is kind of
refreshing in a weird way to say because
before that's what you always used to
lean on and now it's refreshing again to
be like wow look how insanely great
these visuals actually look it's a it's
a visual feast to behold uh so yeah it
looks like imax i'm ready for i met this
looks like i want to see it as big as
possible which is another catchphrase
but in this case it looks needed all
right guys well follow coy on tick tock
also last thing pierce brosnan's lag
full effect i just want to give credit
it's important when he transforms out of
doctor fate and just that walk
gold charisma that's why he cast pierce
brosnan swag swag i mean now this hodge
looks great who's playing cyclone i
forget her name cause i'm a monster
we're not getting enough we didn't get
much of her here we said we hadn't
gotten a lot of her in general uh she
was great at the panel at comic-con
because her and adam spatcher who asked
forget the name of it centennial thank
you noah centennial they had this we
know all the men
they had this really incredible bond
where they talked about how cool it felt
to play young heroes together and how
the two of them like kind of went
through like superhero training together
and there was like this bond of team
because of that and it was really
special to see everyone in that stage
feel like a family and this is the first
movie sometimes that takes sequels and
everything to build up to and and they
were just really great on on stage
together yeah i completely agree
i love noah's antonio i've said it many
times i'm one of those people who's in
love with that man ready for elder assad
to be a household name he has earned it
ten times definitely fantastic amazing
act very underrated under under
recognize that and whenever he's in some
people we're like albus watch is great
i'm like this guy should be more famous
good he is like he's an amazing amazing
talent of an actor he does lines that
like shouldn't work an invisible man
throughout like there's so much dialogue
i'm like only aldous hodge and i can't
wait to see that in the superhero scale
i love that amanda wall that was like
the connective thread yeah
i absolutely love it she's gonna bring
henry cavill back only amanda waller in
character i hope so i bet it's a
post-credits scene cam it's gotta be
it's gotta be all right guys well what
did you think about this trailer leave
your thoughts down below like i said uh
two minutes ago follow koi on uh tick
tock you can subscribe to us but let's
not end this video without doing a p
gabriel gabriel
now gabriel i know we talked about your
name before but i'm gonna look up what
gabriel means on urban dictionary today
gabriel
now i don't know if you're a guy or a
girl your uh profile photo doesn't tell
us but it says the type of guy who can
make you laugh but has that serious side
of him ooh oh you got duality oh you're
like you're you're like me
gabriel
like i'm hilarious but a violent monster
on the inside
just like you yeah he gets what he wants
when he wants it oh you are just as
abusive as me that's good to know
we
need to abuse our way to the top
and don't get me started on his dimples
gabriel's got great dimples you can sit
from a mile away that's what people
always say about my dimples too you and
i have the dimps he tends to be kind of
quiet but only when he is making a dirty
plan we're perverts gabriel
never trust a silent name he never
trusts us pervs but he has a side where
he can think of him as a brother
that's true we are perverted with our
brothers
and you never want to hurt him no
because we will abuse you with our
pervertedness yeah gabriel's a perverted
abuser here you can
tell
you can tell gabriel whatever and he'll
listen and if he likes you enough he'll
tell you stuff about him he wouldn't
even tell his mom yeah like all the
dastardly abuses he's committed that's
great oh my god gabriel i hope you can
confide in me considering we have so
much in common the secret of the dimps
we are just as good and just as awful
simultaneous there's nothing really
awful here about gabriel
that we know of however uh i i think
that you and i both know we got some
dark deeds within us
no we're both little devils on the
inside
ambish
impish gabriel sexy gabriel thank you
unless you're a woman you are lovely to
be around gabrielle
[Music]